oh there he is cinnamon toes
[Music]
minecraft you know well whoever the
years gone what why we come back to
Minecraft because it's awesome how dare
don't ever sneak back - no don't do it
please the whole we just started we just
uh don't jump that we should be slain
why we here on top of this thing first
in right okay right so this is my block
right yes this mode is called sky block
the world famous scotlock I don't know
it's like the top rated mind I've never
played it I don't know anything about it
except that you start off in the sky
with nothing but a pack of ice and some
lava cuz I see love in there there's
eyes and lava I I mean I don't I I may
have taken the ice and loved it but look
also cam there's island over there
there's a block what's below us anything
Hey look at cinema I mean you son of a
biscuit can't say the child-friendly
that's right let's keep it
child-friendly alright so how do we play
this 9 year olds I actually don't know
you said you watch this like back back
back in the day way back in the day yeah
so he makes sense to get the wood first
right oh god am I doing this wrong white
oak good the wood were crazy huh are you
crazy I get out put it back okay we all
have one block alright hey sorry we have
to live off this thing this thing has to
give us apples and stuff so we can
survivor when the DAO but we can keep
the top bid it will still be intact I
think yeah why you know I think we start
off with tree cuz we can make a
workbench out of this one block right
right right right I gotta get I get my
head straight hang on so I need to be
the like overexcited person that's here
with you right
alright one needs to be stale and
understand how the game works and the
other one needs to be like really funny
and weird that's too silent no one likes
it so you got you got what again
lava and water right yeah but how do you
yeah but how do I know what is it no you
fool I thought it was all right
pocket oh oh maybe I'll restart this
Everage okay we're back in back in
gamers you know last time was just a
test don't well it's just a test to say
how what not to do
yeah but we got elite sales you know
don't
old school minecraft pros right guys we
play this game since before most you
were born yeah you're right already
your children your little children no
can't you're scaring the children can
you're scaring the wait does it look
like I'm actually out signer oh my god
explain this scientist Wow yeah if the
earth isn't flat then what is this then
huh what is this geez how do you okay we
got to get going
we got to do stuff okay so so what we
have in the Box we have lava and ice yes
okay okay I got a think let me see how
many spaces do we have how many deep are
they they're three-deep one two three
yeah yeah yeah three times maybe all
right right no no no careful careful
can't keep it going oh I think put the
ice here with the ice there yeah you're
crazy can you're crazy well you will get
lava right does the ice turn into water
if we break it water in
but it turns into cobblestone right now
that works so like you know I love it
there okay put the lava like here in
that one by the box okay but grab that
you almost made him put it in the dirt
we need every block of dirt every blow
right all right come on get your head
again here we go okay okay what happens
if you if you break the ice as it turn
to water no no no he doesn't doesn't
doesn't isn't it okay how do you make
the ice turn to water what if we put it
like right next to it like not next to
it but like right next to it I'm saying
yeah okay okay okay so like here here we
put it there should I put it there I
mean we could try I don't think it's
gonna work like we want it you don't
think it's gonna okay okay Kay what
about this we put it here but put one
two three
huh nothing okay okay I'm going right
one two three
[Music]
nothing we can't pick that back up can't
we
no like I don't know if maybe if you can
like dig under it and then like melt it
from the bottom reach maybe from the top
it's usually goes from top through this
bedrock here bedrock Wow we've where's
the diamonds it bro broke don't even bro
at me bro okay but put it put it put it
that yeah yeah yeah that's the right way
okay okay
how are you ready for this yeah I'm
ready for this we'll see it what is ice
in this game we're trying to do science
here you know all the comments are like
I'm cringing so hard because all we have
to do
look gamers okay we know what we're
doing with will oh yeah yes we know what
we're doing we're just showing other
people what not to do we're just testing
your Minecraft knowledge show this video
to your mind for crafts girlfriend and
then you can be like oh what no what are
you doing Oh what it didn't work wait
come back
[Laughter]
why did you tear that I told you he
doesn't work I'm a Minecraft man right
now I have to restart the freakin
service okay well we know that we now we
know that's the way you don't do okay
I'm trying to tell you feelings it
doesn't work if you break ice cinnamon
toast kid oh there's an orc from
breaking the ice this time you lay with
James Charles doesn't mean I'm like that
how do we melt the ice this isn't making
four maybe you need some time right
maybe or maybe needs to be if it turns
into the next debate wait wait wait
maybe put the ice on top of the the dirt
tray they don't dig under the dirt so
that way it doesn't turn our block of
water into cobblestones that make sense
I don't know what your idea is my idea
is to put the lava on the bedrock I mean
the ice on the bedrock in the pit of
lava over but we can do your idea cause
breaking the ice work I know I know
okay look I'm messed up that's fine okay
you mean put that put the ice here and
then put the lava underneath there's
clearly bedrock here for a reason right
so we don't dig ourselves death probably
no but why isn't it why is it not here
then it's not yeah it's not on this it's
ah well I think we it's because we need
to use it's on that okay okay well tell
me what to do something I don't know I'm
just saying I'm just like looking with
my minecraft eyes right right right
right right so how many it goes three
deep one two okay we can dig one more
nope nevermind what the hell did I count
wrong one two three I'm an idiot
we lost a block Ken Oh God okay we'll
just edit that okay cool
let's try the eye side eh yeah let's do
your eyes like there first and then we
do mind if that doesn't work put a block
right put a dirt block right back here
again right okay so exactly like before
well no I told you to put the dirt back
down we just stood there not paying
attention to me oh I'm sorry
yeah you should be all right let's see
it melt then oh wow it's melting so good
look at it go oh my feet that's looking
hold
are we are we are wait it's ice-cold so
you let me put on top of it well what
did we do before no I wanted to put the
ice on the bedrock I don't know maybe
okay you know what
let's let's explore maybe there's other
things in here oh I get it I get it you
need to burn the tree yeah yeah that's
it okay the tree doesn't burn what is
this game there's anything burned this
lava burn anything only you burn okay
let's look let's look around let's use
our brains they all get a tree I don't
know I just will assume that you can use
something to make it into water melt the
ice you know but nothing works okay but
here so here's the question for you why
do we need water because the lava and
the water will make up of them then we
can make it all the way out there cousin
try to have enough logs right yeah but
we could also we can cut down these and
I think they drop tree branches and then
we get more trees and we can plant the
trees and then more trees more wait it's
so so that we're gonna sit here and
we're gonna wait for trees to grow
listen I don't make the rules of
Minecraft okay we got to make it across
look I'm almost there these are supposed
to be every Islands like a puzzle that
we got to figure out how to make it work
we're given everything we need all right
we've gotta make that we got criticized
in the water I'm telling you it's not
how to do it oh look I got a stick it
came from the tree Oh Oh can can kick in
I got it there is a tree branch there I
didn't google this but I know for a fact
that breaking this I somehow is supposed
to turn it into water I got it I got it
I got it
look what there's nothing here tree take
that
[Music]
three said again break the ice
okay new brain let's try and blame my
kids game alright I'm in again I'm
looking up ice right now it says you can
break it and turn it into a water block
creating water ice can be used to create
water by either melting it or being
broken if there's another block directly
underneath the ice block the ice will
revert to water when broken with it
really you just need to break it
it's what says if there's another right
underneath it while you do your stupid
ice thing this guy is gonna say dear I
didn't uh everything's fine it's me
drown all right well I'm finding a lot
of tree stuff here dude like this is why
well it became ice again possible I was
a waterbender oh I got a tree I'm dead
okay so now we plant three nice look at
this okay okay so and then now you lost
the block cut stop stop losing block you
stop I'm making cobblestone give me that
lava put that love on that spot right
there you still have a gun I don't have
it did you not take it I'll get it
okay okay just don't hurt don't hurt
tree it didn't it almost worked
we're close it has to be flowing lava
oh okay so make these be the okay maybe
I need to reset the map again is that is
that what we have to do Ken yep but
we're on the right track gamers all
right well maybe if you ask me next time
what you're gonna do
doing you're the one that just taught me
to do it it's the worst minecraft
experience yeah it's good for videos
though all the gamers out there just
raging their face off right now
now they know they know they will never
be this good you will never be this
minecraft minecraft choice friendships
okay alright so now okay you do your
little dude first try I got an oak
sapling oh are you still doing the tree
we have done you don't understand
minecraft if you think trees aren't
important trees they're not they're fun
over there somewhere I need the space
game work well the tree needs space to
grow oh my god how am I supposed to make
a lava infinite conduit here through a
deer here do it here how many spaces do
is it even on the top one two three four
through theoretics and careful with the
blocks gosh he hits me off
can they be yeah there we go so I need
to make it still water oh maybe I need
it it's like what do you need to make
the Waterford make the border so
thinking make the water Ken yeah hey
where can that work
what can I work we didn't work here just
put the water no he's not ready
hang on and neither was oak tree and you
killed don't worry okay
don't go near oak tree I swear I will
sorry sorry sorry I didn't damn distance
you almost a toast at me rather I'll
stand up snap anyone that goes near oak
tree cool maybe I'll work over here by
box then and you can grow trees over
okay I'll work okay listen listen listen
but the water here and then you have
lava flowing here okay yeah I'm gonna go
put the lava
yeah yeah right here where's yeah I got
a bucket right okay yeah yeah yeah the
ice down no break the ice scoop it back
run over there
you ruin oak tree every time we reset
oak tree dies that's why I'm really mad
the lava needs to be flowing Ken okay so
the lava lava needs to be flowing water
okay what it doesn't matter okay glowing
lava to be 500 part series let's try to
get off the first okay okay I got I got
it I understand now watch me get open
first tray oh no I did right cuz someone
okay wait wait I got it I got it I got
okay I got tree I got tree don't go near
my tree or I hate to be a dick okay now
do your thing and I'll all supervise
okay so you'll pick up here yes lava
here right no no no lava needs to be
flowing lava thank you
now it's flowing now it's you got you
pick up the carrot you scum I don't do
this I think I need to be the water
first before no no no no no and then
okay and then put the hey I'm just gonna
what [ __ ] I move I'm just getting the
water first so I don't mess up the lava
can kick in work together teamwork okay
nobody next team at the teamwork
teamwork teamwork okay okay okay all
right there put the lava there then get
the ice here and then the water will
flow in okay thank you
we got a cobblestone baby that was that
thing that was epic closer maybe we just
have to make more room more room for
lava I got it okay okay okay we got one
cops code yeah
we're getting closer editing it out
idiot give me back my oh okay
don't you dare say those words oh okay
dude I got an apple I got a freaking app
uh-oh
hey drop it oh no
there you go okay all right gamer I have
a tree I'll put down the tree later
actually I'll put them to you all right
so let's make the lava flow as much as
possible
all right oh good all right we lost look
it's fine the water will like run over
to this yeah but the more the more
spaces that it runs over the more lava
will make so if anything maybe we should
remove this box and make the lava flow
from really it's as high as possible so
like this make sense to you where would
I say none of the flowing lava right
yeah and then we need flowing water and
they need to meet so we need like a
separation can I do anything okay they
have to flow into each other they have
to meet put put up put up the lava put
up the lawn pick it up yeah yeah yeah
pick up okay what we're gonna do is
gonna place them as high up as possible
all right but they'll just run into each
other yeah well place scoot scoot over
please
scooch Oh scooch over I'm scooch in okay
so the lava will go from this one the
long tough work it's gonna it's gonna go
everywhere and then that's the point
yeah yeah yeah this is good okay this is
good
yeah yeah we want as much flow you want
to put a water on top okay I got you
yeah yeah yeah maybe like I don't know
how high we should put it and like maybe
you'll make a little shoot avenge me oh
oh you stole it BAM I'm fine
[Music]
I think uh okay all right see okay I
think that was good except oh we save
oak tree as well this is epic
so now my guy we've done this the
hardest way possible this is kid this
Hickory this is good and now we grab our
grab this all the cobblestone with the
tree the tree finally comes into play
they're free I mean the tree okay all
right an oak tree yeah okay and then we
need more tree this is the most this is
intense guys we must get away is there
been no no don't even even sleeping I'm
a microphone inside I know how to do
this by heart
yeah do it no never mind do it wait any
more would do it
that's what person said do it make a
pick all right I'm making a pick so I
can pick your nose now my nose we can
have a picky check to me do you want one
no we have to save you never know what's
gonna need in the next one I'm picking
this stone it look look at it's gonna
make that block or whatever again this
is what I talking about this is what I
was talking to this one I was talking if
I talked about this before you talk
about this I talked about this at the
beginning that we gotta make infinite
friggin dirt
awesome we're killing it yeah we did it
does that mean we solve the food crisis
yeah yeah we don't even need to glow the
stupid oak tree we don't need to grow
you you suck oak tree I'll tell you this
I tell you this okay do you want to
start building the bridge I don't like
bridges so you came in here you get into
me look how did that miss I'll just put
it there in the water and you can jump
in the water
we're on our way baby dude we're awesome
if you need to make a stone pick Nana
we'd say it's called natural resources
and we save them make a stone pick crazy
Foreman PewDiePie do you have any more
materials for me oh yes of course here
you go sir
flip flip flop Oh in the water I will
pick them up you picked them no I got
them I get for keep god fantastic
you're doing great may I say you're very
smart and very handsome like how we're
getting along until like the next puzzle
come here here you go sir the teamwork
makes the PP work got them oh yeah give
it to me oh yeah I've been played a
bunch of Grand Theft Auto roleplay and
there's like a distance thing to your
voice like you get lower the further you
get away so I keep coming I got like
yell at you when I'm far away Oh way too
much like oh yeah we're in the call
together it's fun no it's good yelling
is good keep doing all right how many
more do we need to get across uh well I
don't think we're halfway yet not even
halfway yeah it's pretty far out here
we're getting we're getting near them
oh I see so what's over there on that
island there's a cactus some sand in
another chest another chest sounds
exotic yeah you have such a fun job yes
okay let's switch them do great well
sometimes they burn up it's really nice
like they don't land in the lava all
right here you go Ken you're the new
miner
oh god here I go gamers oh god there's
bridges in Minecraft you could have you
know oh god it's so far it's so far
they're just gonna take forever mine
quicker Chiba liebe but it keeps jumping
the lava yeah stop change your technique
shave you change your face talking to me
like no I can't do that Ken
no I can't change my face and I want to
I got bad news oh it's about to break
our white broke okay
the pic is broken oh no no no I waste I
just please okay
but okay you have one okay perfect I'll
make a new one you have the wood do I
have to win what a question of course I
have the wood you always have the wood
newsy yeah I'm the wood man of course
this is precious be careful okay thank
you
that was beautiful the only time we've
ever given me anything oh yeah how about
the thousands of years and millions of
nine-year-olds you complain more you see
what happens you lose your name aid
privileges you've given me so many subs
that's right everyone's always like
you've gotten so many stuff and pretty
pod I'm like you know it's really not as
much as you think it oh yeah we'll keep
mining this is what it looks like when
we feel like bragging I caught it I
don't know how come on maybe mine it in
my direction if you keep your the lava
there you go dude that's so offensive
you caught them all up pick up pick up
up you right I am a nerd you're right
what oh my god can you not take these
from me can you take these precious
cobblestones
I'm truck run my person that's thumb off
the edge I want to punch you but come on
work the finish I have to eat then there
Ken this episode needs to finish come on
give me give me the pickaxe give me the
pick a you're bored now look okay God so
move turn them into water thank you we
must be like IQ 2004 doing this
did you make it yet so close gamer have
you not made it yet cuz you keep
throwing the material across the edge
Ken well you wanted me to do this I'm
doing it okay I'm doing my best you know
what lit alright fine look look at me
Cattleya mom takes all these good either
you're like a Pokemon master you just
got to catch them all wow this was
really hard Kim I know how many left
probably Tim alright here we go you
ready for this
Oh got it he all right pro-gamer
straight I was pro game I was just about
to say how bro that was
okay we're almost across one - don't
push me now three four five six
don't seven
oh yeah Gaber oh yeah oh yeah oh there's
a melon where do we get and pumpkin
seeds what this is awesome thanks for
watching part 1 of Skype look this is
written that the entrance stretch like
for part 2 and I see you guys next time
Wow by the way I dropped everything ah
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]